hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com i'm a professional
trader and i've been working for several
big investment banks like hsbc or
commerce bank for the past five years in
hong kong
so every day at work i use technical
analysis to help me to take any trading
decision
so this is the reason why i decided to
make a youtube channel
where i try to share with you guys my
experience and show you
the tools that work for me and how to
use them so if you want to know how to
use these tools and how to create your
trading environment
and make some safe and profitable trades
you are in the right place
so today i want to make a quick update
on the bitcoin let's get into it
[Music]
alright guys so for those who haven't
watched uh the video i did two days ago
i was basically saying so this is the
four hours time frame this is the
bitcoin uh for the past
two months just going higher because
institutional clients are buying it as a
hedge
against inflation i was talking about
this in the video i did one week ago
please go check it out it's i think
quite interesting to understand why we
have this rally and so here
i see a converging triangle when you
spot this kind of patterns
it's a very nice thing that you can use
to set up your trains so here
you can see guys when we broke on the
downside right away
let's go one hour time frame so for
those who haven't watched the video i
did on
on the breakouts please go check it out
breakout trading secrets i explain
exactly
how to handle this kind of situations so
here
in the one hour time frame i would be
like this you see i'll try to you know
connect
as many uh points as i can see as i can
here and look
guys when we have the breakout right
away we have a very strong move down
why because well i'm not the only one
that have spotted this triangle all
right we have 10
move down in one hour so you can capture
this move and actually i'm
i'm explaining this very well in my
video on the breakouts you should not of
course you can
you should not uh take the short
position here you should wait for
confirmation here we have confirmation
and then
find some selling uh levels where you're
gonna enter your short position
for example the breakout level is a very
nice level so here
not sure you would have been executed
but you put your your trades around 32
000
and then you take your short position
and guys look here once again three
hours later you make ten percent
so now uh we having this triangle so i
was basically saying that
most likely we're gonna break on the
upside right because usually converging
triangles that
uh continuation patterns and they
usually break
into the direction of the larger degree
wave which is here bullish
all right i think that the situation is
not bearish yet all right on the shorter
time frame it looks a bit bearish but
actually it's gonna be
wrenchy to me so guys look at this so
let's go back on the four hours time
frame
and try to apply all the different
things for those who have watched my
video that i usually apply
and tell me what you see here all right
you can't tell me but
try to look at it and tell me you need
to adapt all right the situation has
changed
but are we bearish or are we bullish all
right this is the question we have
and look guys once again i'm used to it
but when i look at this chart i see
right away look what we're having right
now so first thing the 200 period moving
average is a support
support here support here here as well
here
a broke but only on a it hasn't
confirmed and here
support as well all right guys so you
can see that
first we are bullish we have the 200
period moving average that is a strong
support
and we have something even better look
at this guys
look what is happening right now on the
bitcoin here
i can see it because we have here this
the the previous consolidation was
bottoming at 28 000 all right
so this is a level i have in mind for a
while
and here it played out but not very uh
it was not very clean around we had some
fake breakouts but here again
guys now you know it's kind of obvious
we had it here
three times here three four times with
one fake breakout
and now here again so guys look what
we're having right now
we're having the same triangle but
descending all right so the basis is
horizontal and the resistance is a
downward sloping trendline
all right guys so now we're gonna use
the same techniques that i told you
about in the video
i did two days ago to enter this trail
i'm still bullish i'm still bullish
because once again
this triangle which is a descending
triangle this time is still a
continuation pattern
i'm still bullish and what is nice to do
here guys is to buy
this level what is going to happen right
now and let's see i like to take some
risks i like to give you my view
and then if i'm wrong i adapt but anyway
you know we're trading with the tight
stop-loss so we're not losing money
now this is what is happening guys okay
and you can see that
this is what's gonna happen i think and
if i'm wrong
it's fine it's fine because you use a
tight stop loss and then we adapt and we
check the next situation so
let me just explain very quickly what i
would do in this situation
so i would buy at 28 all right just
above 28
500 all right 28 29 000 around this
build up some long position you can you
know make some sell
at 35 so you can you know benefit from
some 20
moves all right you can sell here by
here you can do this for a while guys
look look at the the time frame
i think that before we converge here we
converged
here and then there was the breakout but
now we have more time
so i think that the situation is going
to remain like this
for at least like until feb the fifth of
feb something like this
and then let's see if we have a breakout
on the upside
then the next level is 55 000.
i'm gonna show you very quickly for
those who haven't watched my video how i
find
this level so 90 percent move up guys
all right
so and how much you're going to risk not
that much you put a tight stop loss here
right even five percent is enough so you
have five
two hundred so one to twenty risk reward
ratio
very beautiful trade to do you're gonna
tell me all right but you know the
bitcoin is very
wild i know that and maybe the trade is
going to be stopped and then it's going
to
be actually a winner that can happen but
look here
if you put five percent for example
all right so the first one you have it
you can benefit from this move
the second one you would have been
stopped but the third
fourth fifth six ones would have worked
all right so it's okay not to get all
the winners
uh without getting stopped it's fine to
be stopped and then actually your trade
is a winner
just you know repeat this operation i
mean it's not an advice it's what i
would do
i would repeat this operation as long as
28 000 is a support i would be buyer
here
seller here and i would actually build
up some long position that i would keep
here i would not sell everything here i
would wait for the breakout
and if the breakout happens then you
know guys it's perfect
it's perfect because you're building up
some position you take some profits you
buy one
for example you buy two you sell one you
buy two you sell one and so when it
breaks out on the upside
you still have one and usually actually
things are like this it might even be
like this
bam bam and bam so here you can still
buy the retest if you haven't
bought enough here very quickly i just
show you
how i found 25 000 because it's
interesting i use
fib extensions all right so fibonacci
extensions are just
a technique that is assuming that the
next wave is going to be a fibonacci
ratio so ground the number ratio of the
previous waves
once again the golden number ratio is
everywhere in the world it's in the
different
pyramids it's in the shell of a snail
it's in the trees it's in the plants in
the flowers everywhere
and you of course have it in finance you
can find this number in everything that
is growing the market
is growing all right so you have this
number here as well
so i measure the wave the last wave so
one two
three all right we're having a three
right now so i measured this wave
applied to the bottom here and i found
my fib extension ratios so 35 000 is the
first one
so that's why we're having this
consolidation at this level guys this is
not a surprise all right
and the next one is going to be 55 000
and you're gonna see that if we go to 55
000 and i think we're gonna go there
you're gonna have some selling pressure
all right guys so that's it for me i
hope you guys enjoyed this video if you
did please don't forget
to click on the like sub and bell button
so you're gonna be the first to know
when i upload anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys